bon alors on doit regarder qui a ouais
d'accord et siala cédant leurs minables
n'aura qu'une cabine d'un blog ce soir
ah oui alors attendez je peux regarder
je te plaît alors on va vous dire ce
qu'ils voient dans la cabine à bluff
révèle votre vous dire ce qu'ils voient
nord était minable c'est magnifique de
voir ce cadre assez deviner si moi je
vais voir aussi les chroniqueurs et les
chroniqueurs et que s'ils sont payés
vous allez nous dire ce que vous voyez
dans la cabine apple c'est magnifique
je suis sûr que chez vous s'est énervé
chéri vous rêvez de voir défiler tout et
son folk pourquoi parce qu'elle est en
deux temps toujours tu as vu ça aussi
moi j'ai fait moins appel à revoir c'est
incroyable alors il a qu à à un indice
ils sont deux à battre a dit on va pas
vous faire de propositions on a
tellement rigolé à votre avis qui garde
la famine dans la cabine à bluff
bernard aussi les deux noms elle est
dans le film
non c'est raté c'est raté plutôt boudeur
alors bouder ah c'est pas une réponse
qui est très exagéré l'approximatif
c'est approximatif bouder avec ramzy
avec rami on est sur un duo de cet
acabit mais non lauder avec eric judor
désolé à s'échouer non alors
bouder avec ramzy ouais je vous dire
justement ya ramzy qui a pas pu venir
soit parce que ce n'est pas la bonne
réponse qu'a voulu vous laisser un petit
message à jamel à kiev à vanessa ont
regardé hier hamdi qui vous a laissé un
message regard des professionnels
ouais mais maîtrisant son sujet car et
connaissant son texte muscu ou beauté
coiffure jeu correct jeu qu'il faut
donner au gouvernement tous dans le
regard bon copain bon vraiment bon mais
fidel fidel jamais la même basse et pas
muscu déjà way et mais en revanche
vivacité d'esprit impressionnant c'est
impressionnant l'impressionnante je
dirais il est une musique dans son
spectacle qui le résume bien sa musique
de son année spectacle qui s'appelle la
puissance c'est la princesse vous allez
en prendre encore mia il étudie neige
très fort mais n'a jamais été aussi fort
[Applaudissements]
sa balle franchement les différents
échanges
non c'est vraiment gentil ce qu'ils ont
dit et c'est vraiment des mecs
incroyable et pour le coup je le dis ils
ont raison par rapport à jamel
je trouve incroyable dans ce film et si
je peux me permettre
eux aussi ils sont incroyables dans le
fils en forme allez-y pour les génies
aussi parce que c'est dingue
djamel eric ramzy moi ça me touche
profondément votre message j'aimerais
vous dire que j'ai aucun respect pour
vous alors émus du mépris un peu de
nulle part et à la désinvolture total à
ce qui concerne justement justement des
rebelles moi je vous adore mais
redémarre moselle semblaient alors
justement les mecs on me dit qu'en fait
le ils n'ont en fait on a laissé un
petit peu tourné après l'interview et on
a les images sont à leurs yeux
non merci
à tort de s'asseoir et les meufs
j'aime bien que c'est pas tellement
moi j'aime pas choquer la même terrasse
pas qui c'est formidable
balladur a laissé les jeux pan nous
faire attendre plus autant ceux qui sont
là voilà on va ils sont dans le film ils
sont exceptionnels aussi c'est bouder
notre conseil
c'est un auteur l indice ils sont deux
dont un animal un petit animal poilus
regardez ces bouder et wahid
allez
[Musique]